in 2015
fnatic csgo team dated the impossible
they showed the csgo world what true
dominance looks like once again we got
fnatic is always a pleasure to pretend
against me I think they're the best in
the word right now Swedes are like
Koreans in StarCraft you just can't keep
them down they win absolutely everything
I think we're gonna keep just keep
playing good keep dominating online I
guess
mahalik since joining Malik has probably
been being able to be a full-time gamer
and becoming the number one team in the
world
the team won three valve majors a feat
no team has been able to match since and
even more impressively they won two of
those majors back-to-back and they did
so at a time when csgo was blowing up
when ESL one Katowice was the first csgo
tournament to break a million concurrent
viewers in 2015
caminito champion Tom pedantic csgo was
emerging as one of the biggest eSports
in the world and fnatic or front and
center
[Music]
cinetic had won their first major with a
different roster but it was your 2015
lineup that truly came to the fine of
the t JW Crim's russia pronax and
olofmeister in 2015 at the height of
their power the swedish fnatic french
ldl-c and polish virtus pro lineup
battle for the top spot in the scene but
the sleeves often came out on top
Dreamhack France 2015 and defeating NV
fnatic just dominant outright at this
last map and this definitely was not
that tooth and nail battle that we were
expecting to see in the final battle oh
thanks like that's right this is my turf
now individual skill was one of the
biggest factors in fnatic success they
had four of their players recognized in
HL TV's top 10 players for that year the
team was winning tournaments left and
right and while phonetic was playing
incredible counter-strike the sleeves
did have their fair share of controversy
because it wasn't fair against LLC it
was a dirty trick in my opinion yeah but
then again there's no real clear rules
against it so you can't really blame
fnatic for doing it
we've thought it was legal when we did
it but afterwards we understand it I
don't think it's legal benefits to like
to our power we didn't kill them
understand that because we never used it
they were famous or infamous at the time
for their youth in the Olaf boots we
coach while he's here he sees them now
this straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's gonna be a fun
you're trying to see if they could
potentially get a cleaner shot look at
this now happy getting boosted up but he
gets spotted all eyes there sees it
coming
16:13 destruction rain down about ldl-c
accusations of cheating also floated
around the team there were some members
of the community that were certain the
flusher with cheetah someone
[Music]
of course through some gentlemen I know
that a couple of my teammates are
convinced that they think that she threw
it all the team managed to put up win
jumps down tries to find the angle but
washa
instantly reacts playing for the bomb
just trying to burn as much time off of
this clock and Zeus will go down fnatic
take at 1614 the thirtieth round of the
last map after win no that could have
been instant suicide and now worldedit
101 and pronax ends up with a triple and
they're gonna win the round JW at 31
kills and a 1610 score line your faces
to Jimmy
fnatic will pot heading into ESL one
kind of beats 8th 2015
they were only slightly eclipsed in the
power ranking by team envyus who as team
ldlc won the previous valve major but
ultimately no team was clearly ahead of
the other they were equal contenders and
when cuddly say 2015 kicked off fnatic
looked to be in top form
they destroyed every team they came up
against at least until the grand finals
it has been a record-breaking three days
16 teams whittled down to this today we
will make history as we crown our first
double major champion fnatic won the
first map 16 to 14 in a close game he
really has changed n IP but all of my
still will get him even at 13 health is
legal JW adios gamourai trying to
catalyze in the killing forest goes to
do it again they're coming around the
corner guess what
and this could be phonetic running away
with it aloof old and ever it is
phonetic
they claimed us to next was cashed a map
that nip historically struggled on which
gave fnatic the edge but this time nip
took it 16 to 10 not gonna allow you to
they're still trying get right Caesar
coming you know right where the killer
improves its pro next this is the last
round of the harp and pronax goes down
thing is that they don't know all the
points up there now they do Freiburg
sees it goes for the kill gonna pick it
up
it marked phonetics first Matt lost the
entire tournament but they didn't let it
throw them all the a push is alive it's
exist you'll get the first frag to
four-flusher
as he looks put up the three
on the other hand they've washed a low
to the hands of JW count right going for
the deck cut off my stuff with a
headshot picks him up through it all of
my staff Kent fighting in the same spot
off my graveyard and trims when he's in
the site oh there it is now it's on
exist 1 V 2 here finessing they could be
the second or the first teams were in a
second championship here on global
Offensive and Oliver West's player so
safely they know that they have it if
sis gets one and he's back wallet he's
got the kid he's holding it down I'm not
sure there's enough time
ladies
kennedy to champion the win marked the
horns second major victory fnatic became
the first team with two valve major
titles itching their name in cs:go
history and with how dominant their win
was many were looking to fnatic to see
if they could do something even greater
after cut of eats a phonetic continued
their reign of dominance
they seemed untouchable all the way up
until the next major ESL one cologne
2015 going into Cologne fnatic were
favorite to win the tournament and once
again the team didn't fold under the
pressure that's the wall not taken down
low stop old on Berlin and he will be
finished off by Quincy's fnatic picking
up the victory sixteen rounds to two
deagle a dream ladies and gentlemen it
was all too easy for fnatic 16 - as they
absolutely decimate the opposition in
their groups they're gonna be going
through quarterfinals of everybody in
this tournament will want to avoid that
quarter-final clash the team easily made
playoff taking 32 rounds and only giving
up four in the group stage in the
bracket stage they took on a
luminosities Brazilian roster and
destroyed them one train rotates when
they get around the back there but
pronax on flusher just gonna gunned down
the beat defense is firs gonna cover but
JW is in no looser let them slip and it
will be a very simple 16-5 for fnatic
they made it look easy in their first
map and they close it out in two and
while they gave fnatic a hard time on
Mirage the Swedes came out on top stays
to keep himself a moment a breather
Shelley needed to land they know his
position they're gonna try and push him
down he needs the Swiss - missed
fanatical taken we will get a diffuse is
16:14 fanatic they moved through to face
Buddhist Pro in the semi-finals virtus
Pro were next and they hid fnatic their
first map loss in the entire tournament
on the raw I think is it going it's a
pops at the moment plush and passionate
rating it out and it doesn't like us to
me a3 b2 all Pasha with a double you can
see all five setting their sights on and
they're picking up the pace this could
very well be the end fanatics another
fnatic bounced back with a tight 16 to
14 win on inferno
I'm a little bit of a problem is Crim's
stroll through mid claims control and
now fnatic swarming once worth the site
it comes down to be Ani to try and deal
with this when he can't cribs are not
over there to try and take further SPRO
towards match point Pro nice goes down
it's out down to just has one V to
towards match point 15 to 13 is it a
chance as well he gets thankful about
Jake W says no and once again fnatic
hold on like you look at that
this is gonna be a slaughter flush
against what gets you get three he can
or easy companies that's a full Russia
close-up by max we don't touch just yet
we're going to a third map is
cobblestone virtus pro at being at that
final hurdle here I'm fanatic finally
standing back up and so it all came down
the cobblestone to pour through towards
the a side they're all there Russia stop
beam as they walk up the beyond even
what watch Reaper on the joint my poor
next swatch see the white jewelry does
patients may be a virtue flash comes out
here we go in fnatic a once again
looking dominant he gets one he gets the
tackle the second but he could not get
the fraggin fnatic once again looking
dominant on today W manages to avoid one
Lake to thrashes as he knows that three
he's managed to avoid the volumes up
keep dragging and he gets brunettes book
ribs and all off collide
all on me oh look at this plate one
three to thirty seconds
oh thank you their way to the finals in
pressure Panetta corn at Seaside
outstanding play the sleeves were on
their way to grand finals on their way
to their second consecutive major win
the only team standing in their way was
the French powerhouse team envyus
they hadn't played against fnatic and a
major since the infamous old office I'll
be it with a slightly different roster
and Aeneas had gone through some a line
of changes ahead of Cologne adding star
offer Kenny s and entry Fragger apex and
their run to the grand finals almost
mirrored fanatics something to know both
teams have only dropped one map coming
into the finals MV just two against TSM
and same for fnatic the only drop that
one map against VP in the semifinals on
Mirage so both of them pretty much a
clean record coming in just tested to
their limits in the semis the first map
with dust to enemy hasn't pet the game
was ten to five for envious at halftime
which meant that for fnatic to win they
needed a really good T side there's the
flash that's gonna catch creams out
there gonna push off through and BK gets
robbed the crib through the spray down
tip top
done yet Grimm's around the corny pants
aw he finds question but he doesn't
manage to land a clean shot now cribs is
he gonna come to the rescue once again
it does have other photos in the corner
but NASA closed out the round it was so
close though
they are just hanging on by a thread
smoking because Russia doesn't let her
choose the throw it down he's all the
way over in tunnels but it doesn't
matter when they're landing shots like
this will be all the time in the first
map of the Grand Finals can't believe
her how has this happened they were so
far away from this in the euphoria they
must be feeling right now after getting
back into this and it came down to some
amazing situations the map went into
overtime and when it did fnatic pulled
out something crazy and look at the guns
Oh
aw peas ready they're ready to shoot
some ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and
not in this lifetime he is destroyed
he's gonna run screw with the deagle
looking for this job but he can't make
it he's gonna get shut down by flusher
18 to 15 a single round for fnatic and
we'll have seen
the most ridiculous comebacks ever in a
major tournament here ends will be so
vital Crim's is in a perfect position as
well they have a great little crossfire
and BK gets one but they don't count for
flush it's a still be there NES just
smokes you off but flushes not having
anybody's gonna push off through he's
gonna come down Teddy and Kirishima now
all the life into the crosshairs of all
of my stuff just signs of the shot gets
the supporter flusher and this will be
fantastic
taking map one on dust2 1952 saw JW
they're pushing on this short the last
one evening we need to make something
happen finds that cutter no fee but this
just shows you how equally still these
teams are Kenny Ezra flying straight
back in there
so it's such a passion for grandpa but
now take take map number one and what a
story it's been they were only one map
away from making theater history one map
away from the third major and their
second the consecutive one one map away
from greatness you sign that something
just one very wrong but they actually
got the right call anything any this
time they're getting shut down in that
beat bombs side they don't have armor
they've got one flashbang on a pitch and
he's very nearly dead get themselves
round but they have to start maddening
the shots and cribs it's just gonna get
a beautiful spray down alongside pronax
attack has been stopped dead in his
tracks JW will manage to lab the third
shot MBK now all alone gets himself one
for sure but that will be all they got
not sure and all of - the very close to
the action here or not gonna be peeked
into the middle of a flashbang and
fluster thinking of a kill on MBK that's
gonna give them serious problem as a fix
gonna come around the side picks the a
cops out on top in the straight-up wanna
want Joel and Oh Kenny and happy for all
that stand in the way of fanatic sports
III look at the speed coming into it
here grenade on through and enry they're
speeding up JW missing a couple of shots
and they gets goin return products on
the back lines and they're gonna get
that refracts here very annoying health
is happy and they just keep on training
it through they can't stop now all off
with a kill as well it's gonna be Kenny
with refract reneedar in Happy's on six
health and ladies and gentlemen it's
gonna require a miracle and nothing less
for happy to make it out I don't think
there's any chance flush you're looking
to end
third major championship in global
Offensive while water weight efficient
fnatic became the first and only csgo
team to win three valve majors and they
won two of them back-to-back walks a
moment it is on a fine scale you look
like you can't believe him I don't want
to savor this I don't know I don't know
what to say I've never played their
first game they're coming back I don't
know what saying
short the Brazilian luminosity SK roster
has one consecutive major sins but
fnatic did it first and no one can take
that away from them they cemented their
place in CS history forever and at a
time when CS co was exploding a time
with a game needed Giants fnatic was
there they carry each other they lift
each other up they make them all better
than any of them could be individually
and that's what we're seeing that's why
they're the greatest all time that's why
they went to back-to-back and three over
else three of those players from fnatic
have won three majors including the
first major white record that's that
right there is legendary no matter the
game the history that right there is
incredible
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button